foreign
[Music]
ER
Rich boys
get down on your knees
[__] him up
we gotta go
thank you
it was a Finnish Commander lost his home
and his family in the war he became a
one-man Death Squad
[Music]
foreign
mean [__] that you do not want
to mess with
[Music]
you'll see what happens when you take
everything from him
he's Immortal no he just refuses to die
how many Minds did you bury here all of
them
you
and you
it's not about who's the strongest this
is about not giving up
we have a word for that in Finland
we might have a problem
this hit goes out to you Mr Wick
42 regular wasn't it yeah
and so it begins
challenging into single combat if you
win it will have your freedom
amen
the only way John Wick will ever have
freedom
and peace
[Music]
yeah not really
welcome home
I know this place isn't as warm as I'd
hoped
but I'm going to light a vanilla candle
and it's going to be a game changer
we're out
this Mansion is unhinged she needs all
the help she can get you want to be a
hero
pass two thousand dollars what's the
address
[Music]
a little help
this house has a way of Playing Tricks
on you
[Music]
oh my God is anybody else seeing this
yeah I'm seeing it
careful
with lurks around every corner
other more powerful entities may come
through not on our watch what are you
gonna do
seriously they're already dead you're
gonna be deader okay
[Music]
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
said it was clear I said the front was
clear
ah front back right wrong anyway shall
we I have another job for you so what we
got Greg Simmons the billionaire arms
dealer oh a lot very serious faces up
here in there you can't catch this fish
with conventional lures I'm sorry The
Lure being Danny Francesco
the movie star Greg Simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's the guy very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you I'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law I actually love my
sister-in-law
you made that quite evident when Marine
they're all the killers
you're an actor I
know with someone pinch me please is
that Danny Francesca what's next for you
I'm playing a mysterious self-made
billionaire he just described me shadow
me do whatever I do whatever I do to who
I am whoever Greg was buying from I was
amongst you last night
I can get inside of them
I hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
what happened he recognized your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name covers blown
what do I do the movie star's gonna melt
did you stopped any Francesca you
stopped Simmons you let me worry about
that
what are you gonna do with that I'm
gonna shoot at them Danny
oh
so you weren't seen by anyone yes that's
a yes to one scene by anyone yes or yes
you were seen by someone yes
it was the most beautiful thing I'd ever
seen
I played for five minutes I still see
falling blocks in my dreams
it's poetry art and math all working in
magical synchronicities
perfect game Tetris Tetris Tetris Tetris
Tetris I don't get it
It's a combination of tetra Greek for
four and tennis tennis the Russian
inventor he likes tennis
this game isn't just addictive it stays
with you this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity and only 10 other people in
the world have seen what you're about to
see
it's called The Game Boy packaging with
Tetris can you get us the rights
the show Butte Union had worldwide
rights nothing gets out easily I'm gonna
go to Moscow you're walking into a
country they're still considers America
enemy Numero Uno okey dokey
you sure you don't have to talk to your
wife about this first Pioneers have to
bet the house to win but not literally
listen
have you ever heard our apartment this
quiet before
this is the inventor of Tetris your game
is brilliant I'm Gonna Make You A
Millionaire mystologists have you ever
negotiated with the Soviets
we're here for Tetris
what do you say I don't speak Russian
the most powerful men in government
started watching you and your family do
you know where your husband is what the
hell is going on the world is changing
and Soviet Union will not be left behind
you want to play with the big boys this
is how the world Works where is my money
this is insane we can't protect you
sometimes you gotta forget you
same again
this is Criminal
Soviet Union is about to implode they're
lying everybody's lying the Cavalry is
coming we don't have time I have a plan
come on you guys are the kings of
Cliffhangers
[Music]
tell me
how did you come to Neverland
oh
You Lost Boys every last one of us
but you're not all boys so
what is this place it's home
just like you found all of us
reflecting someone else
what'd she say boys you're a different
Adventure
it looks very far away it's close with
anything
there look
what is it that you're afraid of my love
perhaps I don't want to grow up
hold the past in your heart but where
you go from here it's up to you
darling
whatever is Peter Pan
[Music]
what's the job we're gonna destroy their
whole nuclear program
breaking news exposing the cia's
sabotage of Iran's nuclear reactor it
covers blood we're leaving 15 minutes
stretching point
I just want to go home and I'll be with
you
the distance is not the main issue
that's what's in between
I didn't even catch mine guys I'll sell
them to the highest bidder
[Music]
no one is coming to rescue us
we have to get to candor
get down
seven years ago one incredible story
blew up the internet when I was 22 I got
involved with the Russian mafia I was a
frat boy on a class trip this is Igor
he's here for your protection he's very
dangerous and we're not to talk to or
hang out with him all I want to do is
hang out with him I did not speak
Russian
it was literally the best summer of my
life we robbing this guy
23 years after those events
the story continues what is wrong with
this shirt
yeah machine not today brother not today
my dad showed up you paid money to see
my son tell his made-up story about
robbing a train for the million times
it's a true story it took about two
seconds before he started making me
mental look at it
he's a monster
are you the machine ma'am the party's
outside 23 years ago you stole the only
thing my father ever cared about sorry
this some sort of tick-tock prank I'm
about to lose my [__] it's definitely a
prank clearly that's a fake gun
or not you're coming with me back to
Russia
why are you talking about fast like
Heroes Peter something
funny more drugs
[Applause]
bird take off that shirt and show those
sobs who you really are now you got a
party with me
he's the machine
[Music]
fine oh he's gonna shoot him in the leg
oh my God I'm going to freaking hell I
killed a man well
technically it killed several men
I have terrible news your grandfather is
dead I don't even know him they want me
to fly to Rome tomorrow night to settle
his Affairs I mean shouldn't I stay here
and work on my marriage Kristen start
thinking about you
I landed safe in Italy
what can we go back we have to go to the
funeral
what did my grandfather do
what is going on
my dying wish is that you be the new
boss of the Balboa family
I've got a lot going on at home my son
just went to college and my husband just
cheated on me you want me to take care
of him no
no no no no no
we need someone who's level heading
I'm assuming and empathetic did you just
call me pathetic
we are in the middle of the war with our
enemies
we have to kill those Romanos before
they kill us
like Godfather oh right yeah I never saw
the Godfather
okay look it's really hard to find three
and a half hours
how are we supposed to appear strong
when she is this you look like a
librarian
finally had Italian men yet
to kill the boss our boss takes care of
business I made muffins
I'm a little tired of this war my family
is tired of this war oh my gosh trick
advisor does not lie can I can I get
scoop
hi I'm still in the dark here
figure of speech
[Music]
my parents are inviting us to the Summer
Place for the big Fourth of July weekend
I can't leave my father this is the
first summer since we have to say
goodbye to you dear Mother and you'll
want to leave me to burn the spot
because alone
let's bring it nah I don't think so
you hear this ladies he's worried his
immigrada's gonna make it look like some
kind of Goomba
if we're gonna do this today you gotta
dial it down
what is this
wow this wow this is amazing
[Music]
yeah of an affection then unlike you
when you met me at the delivery room you
chose to shake my hand what else was I
supposed to do we just met
Sebastian I don't know how you're gonna
fit in my team
these people have jobs they got their
money in the stock market that
mayonnaise jars buried in their backyard
I just hope nothing gets stolen this
weekend because these people love to
blame the immigrants
we'll give you the grand tour this is
Doug he's learning to be a Healer hello
what are you doing it's just serenading
our fat peacock
I love you these people are strange say
it burns for a place
like ducks are just a bunch of goddamn
show-offs if you ask me
who's nervous to bring you here but I
didn't know you're gonna spend the whole
time embarrassing me how could you say
that to your father Here We Go Again
everything I'm doing for you that I've
ever done for you is for your own good
hey man check it out I died
I'm trying to make sure that you don't
make an ass out of yourself by trying to
be somebody you're not
oh my god oh [__] Sebastian your suit
it's Versace do you like it no you [__]
it's not up
I would love to make a full Italian
dinner for everybody we don't keep a lot
of food here Amanda scalco always finds
a way to feed his family
my father has an old Italian saying
family isn't one important thing it's
everything I can't believe you put this
all together from what we have in the
kitchen it's artichoke and poultry
absolutely
[Music]
oh no
oh
give a little bit you slide up their pet
peacock and you thought I was crazy for
worrying that you were gonna make us
look like some bad Italian staff that's
right to help me get rid of the evidence
why does it seem like you've done this
before
[Music]
feeling like this
exactly what I see this is what
greatness I need the greatest basketball
shoe that's ever been made what's the
plan we build a shoe line around just
him for a rookie who's never set foot on
an NBA court who's the player Michael
Jordan
we can't get Michael Jordan I'm thinking
to reach out to the parents you talk
directly to the family you're going to
lose your job do you typically show up
at people's front doors unannounced I
was told not to call oh man here we go
every once in a while someone comes
along that's so extraordinary that it
forces change because they are so very
special a shoe is just a shoe until my
son steps into it
air weighted are exclusive in Peters
April 5th
[Music]
the higher you get the harder it gets
this is a war
it's a fight it's a battle
so
how long have you known each other
[Music]
it was like brothers
the past came back too
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back no friends
[Music]
before I got locked up I was the best
power bro and a fraud
watching somebody else live your life
I'm just getting started little brother
I'm coming for it all
it's not gonna stop
you make
the one and only Adonis Creed you're the
best pound fighter in the world three
years ago it's been a minute since
you've been out in these streets when I
walked away from boxing I walked away
with some unfinished business
[Music]
you see that man right there
do you remember him hey hey
back
let's draw everything you've found
anything we've built yeah
let me start fighting
out of the sea
[Music]
wish I could be
part of that world
it's a reunion about the crack we got
the whole crew back really [__] a cabin
in the woods found this kid is all that
perspective for all y'all enjoyment you
still slave to white man I'm gonna stop
calling my wife the white man all right
hell no where are you going look for the
fuse box what the house is this
[Applause]
and she dies
I think we have to play the game in your
predicament the black character is
always the first to die I will spare
your lives if you sacrifice the person
you deemed the blackest to blackest
nobody used to judge anybody in here bro
you have two minutes to decide
y'all can't pick me I'm gay oh Clifton
yeah that can prove him not the blackest
prove it I've never seen Friday
I voted for Trump what
we have to split up
[Applause]
your time has run out it's time to die
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a crazy person oh yeah
Rosa Parks on your shirt right we should
be sitting down right now I mean
that's exactly what she did look
made you look
women gotta save everyone others
you know stop playing
I got a gun
that's too DMX what are you doing
father Gabriella I'm worth
all right
on the night of June 4th
you performed an exorcism
that was not an exorcism
the majority of cases do not require any
exercise
98 I recommend they buy him to doctors
and psychiatrists
the other two percent
I call it
evil
we have more questions for you father
Mort you have a problem with me you talk
to my boss
[Applause]
that needs your attention
bring me the priest
I'm here to help Julia
wrong right
take cautioned their secrets buried
there
it's about the concealer
the church escort against this demon
before
but I can cover it up we need to find
out why
it's whatever you do
because God allows it
imagine what could happen if the devil
possessed the soul of the Pope's
Exorcist who will defend you
my faith
no required defense
the city is for some glamorous
stimulating prosperous
only recently has it become dangerous
[Music]
Jack I think I found something three
women were strangled over the last two
weeks you're on a lifestyle desk you're
not covering a homicide I think the
murders are connected
another woman was strangled just came
over the wire I'm killing the follow-up
you don't have a story how many women
have to die before it's a story
they just confirmed number four
police aren't talking never seen him
this tight-lipped about anything I don't
care if it's one killer of four we're
gonna catch whoever did this
Boston police hands on the wall we had
him we just let him walk away
everything lines up with them his
history the progression of the crimes
everything you know how many people have
gone down the rabbit hole with
it's a dead end every time of this case
what do you think you're gonna find out
there when is this gonna stop Loretta I
need you to call in a favor
be quick
I don't want to get fired tonight any
lawyer worth a dime would pick this
apart
you really want to use this paper to
tear down the police department if
anyone else was blowing it this badly
we'd have put it on the front page a
long time ago I need you to take down an
address if I don't call back in an hour
give it to the police Loretta
there's more than one lunatic out there
and you're gonna get us both killed
little world is just delusion
I thought she moved to another shelter
now you know I was in Rutgers I really
missed you girl yeah and apparently
these rules
[Music]
every just let me see your eyes so I
know you're not mad at me I'm staying
out of trouble this time
[Music]
tell me more about your Foster mother
you like her
oh
would it make you feel better if you
came to stay with me yeah
all right we're gonna go to Harlem where
I grew up at the city had him he's not
supposed to be with me
keep it to yourself where's my dad at
he's gone but you wouldn't like them
anyway I got somebody else in mind Terry
I want you to meet lucky is going to be
moving in with us how long
get that ship off your shoulder I know
you hear me
you are my mom
you're a blessing
for your mom especially
getting older now time for you to start
thinking for yourself
Daryl's a very bright kid have you
thought about MIT Harvard
[Music]
is your mother home maybe it's time to
give him some answers that he'd been
looking for is there all your real name
have you told anyone else about this
when are you going to realize that you
are enough
I got a war for you you know that
against anybody
I guess this whole city but they're not
breaking us up this time
[Music]
someone needed me baby I'm the one who
needed you
[Music]
hey hi you a fighter
I'm just a regular girl who hates it
when bad guys win then you're really
gonna hate me
[Music]
we were a perfect team I was riding the
high
we all know that does the last
you're okay
I caught my sister and my boyfriend of
three years having sex in our apartment
how are you do you have a place to stay
I may know a guy just um be careful he's
complicated
good
no I saw you lose
now I'm the only one who can make sure
that doesn't happen again
I'm training him to break you
[Music]
She's Mine always will be right
maybe we should try something different
some people are lovers it's not gonna
addicted to you
others Fighters
sometimes
it's hard to tell the difference
[Music]
jokes on you
ah dude I barely recognize you freshman
Chang is no more Chang 2.0 is here baby
Kobe
he seemed pretty into basketball so why
aren't you out there then hey Kristy but
it's for you
okay yeah you can dunk so can a lot of
people you can't
[Applause]
hey Pat on the night of last home
football game I bet you I will dunk on
that hoop what are you putting down I
have a first edition Charizard Pokemon
card shadowless yeah we're three grand
so what's the plan this guy she's gonna
teach me how to dunk
hey Deandre and you said you were a
basketball coach you said you were six
foot
give chain can't dunk by our last
football game he's gonna have to move to
another school yikes I'll do anything
you ask me to do we're gonna do a whole
series on
yo I'm changing I'm dunking all my
haters yeah yeah oh you were serious I'm
sorry bro we're gonna work on that
home away from home no weight cause you
in the bar
is that the kid from the main
I have 10 bucks on you dunking oh hey
don't worry my man's got this I didn't
seemed like this before I thought he
quit after a week use that chord Shay
but he didn't
kept going
anybody's talking about you dude it was
five eight he's inspirational
let's go why do you want to dunk so bad
is it really about this bet with Matt
like a dunk it would be proof that I
could be
more than who I am
[Music]
you want to prove it
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
want to get married
ladies and gentlemen Jesse and Emma
learn
why off to Alaska okay I'll call you
when I land
hello Mrs Lerner your husband was on a
helicopter that went down in the Pacific
Jesse at first it was so hard to let go
I refused to admit you were gone
but then I started to think that the
good days could be good weeks or good
months I'm finally ready to live again
Emma Sam I
guess you all know that I've been madly
in love with Emma for a few years now
the family family
hello sweetheart it's Jesse I'm alive
I can't wear that to reunite with your
long-lost husband
I'm engaged
you and Jesse had this beautiful life
together and then we all thought he was
dead and you found love again with a
great guy no matter what you do you're
gonna break somebody's heart
that was incredibly verbose but accurate
[Music]
that was wildly inappropriate I'm gonna
stop no man for God's sakes just keep
talking
[Music]
person that she loves the most not a
person that loves her the most
Henry so don't go tell him
[Music]
I'm gonna talk about your husband-in-law
what I what
Miss Chen what are you doing here look
I'm still pending at Harvard I was just
wondering if you'd heard anything oh
it's Harvard hello you want to give her
a full ride I'll let her know right away
it's funny
do you ever feel like we have wasted our
youth sitting on the sidelines what do
you want us to be doing like games and
parties and dances
wrong will you put a prom with me yeah
yes do you accept the terms and
conditions of my proposal it would be my
honor
slow dancing wow you really know how to
make a boy feel special Harvard is my
life's ambition help me figure out how
to get him you need a killer letter of
rest your team captain
I can't believe I'm about to say this
what about Graham Lincoln's death the
Harvard Alum senator So the plan is we
stage a run-in with the most popular guy
in school at a party that we were not
invited to then ask him for a gigantic
name easy peasy you okay babe yeah I
would love you
[Music]
go bulldog
I'm sorry I'd be happy to tutor you you
know as an apology
is all
you're five minutes late are you really
willing to compromise your values for
some letter of Rec it's up
do you think it's just a dumb jocker for
this did you know who I was before this
why'd you offer to tutor me
[Music]
people come to me with their
expectations of who I am or who I should
be
[Music]
I am not gonna let it Pass Me By
Graham Lansing is not who I thought he
was you are applying to Harvard
we'll look back on high school you think
your biggest regret will be it's nothing
that beats Harvard
is there I'm sorry I didn't catch the
name of the school is it hergards
[Music]
went out with graham Lansing
Graham Lansing oh stop why do you guys
know who that is
there's a word in Korean
it means providence
or fate
do you believe in that that's just
something Koreans say to seduce someone
[Music]
what a good story this is
childhood sweethearts who reconnect 20
years later and realized they were meant
for each other and the story I would be
the evil white American husband standing
in the way of Destiny shut up
there's just this kid in my head for
such a long time I think I just missed
him did he miss you
his song
wow
and the way you move
makes me feel like
the guy flew 13 hours to be here I'm not
gonna tell you that you can't see him or
something
[Music]
if two strangers walk by each other in
the street and their clothes
accidentally brushed
that means there have been a thousand
layers
between them
[Music]
I want you to stay
is
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this is
foreign
[Music]